répondre aux besoins de nos concitoyens
merci madame la parole est à monsieur
thierry mariani merci lorsque l'on parle
d'attractivité de la france monsieur le
ministre du budget il ne s'agit pas
uniquement d'attirer les investissements
étrangers en france
la france doit aussi rester attractive
pour nos compatriotes établis à
l'étranger
or malgré leur attachement à la france
ils sont aujourd'hui de plus en plus
nombreux à hésiter voire à renoncer à
investir dans l'immobilier en france et
ce à juste titre car ils ont été au long
de ces cinq années de votre gouvernement
la cible de votre politique fiscale dès
votre arrivée en 2012
ils ont été frappés vous le savez par
une surtaxe sur les revenus du
patrimoine immobilier pour les non
résidents concrètement cela se traduit
par un prélèvement total de près de 40%
des revenus des loyers perçus en france
et pendant cinq ans nous n'avons cessé
de dénoncer cette mesure les français de
l'étranger subissent désormais de plein
fouet la taxation sur les résidences
secondaires puisque quand on est
expatrié et que l'on garde une résidence
en france
celle ci est automatiquement considéré
comme une résidence secondaire
en effet l'augmentation de la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires est désormais permise par
votre loi de finances 2010 est ainsi par
exemple madame le maire de paris n'a pas
tardé à appliquer une augmentation de 60
% de la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires
monsieur le ministre la résidence en
france d'un français établis à
l'étranger ne peut continuer à être
considérés surtout taxer comme une
résidence secondaire
vous savez que lorsqu'un français
gardent un bien immobilier en france
c'est avant tout pour avoir un pied à
terre pour des raisons familiales c'est
un filet de secours en cas de retour en
france
ma question est donc simple n'est-il pas
temps de considérer le bien immobilier
en france d'un expatrié comme une
résidence principale et non comme une
résidence secondaire
si l'on veut véritablement entretenir le
lien avec la france si l'on veut
véritablement que les expatriés continue
à investir en france si on veut
véritablement qui continue à regarder 20
autres pays la parole est à monsieur
christian eckert secrétaire d'état
chargé du budget et des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs le député monsieur
thierry mariani d'abord je peux pas vous
laisser dire qu'en 2012 les français nos
compatriotes résidant à l'étranger
aurait subi une taxation supplémentaire
il ya tout simplement un principe
d'égalité devant l'impôt qui doit être
respectée à se voir que les français
résidant en france sur le revenu
immobilier acquittent de la csg et de la
crds il n'y avait aucune raison pour que
nos compatriotes résidant à l'étranger
n'acquittent pas la même contribution et
c'est cela et ce n'est que cela que qui
a été voté par cette majorité
effectivement en 2012 vous soulever la
question de la nature des propriétés des
français résidant à l'étranger de lors
de leurs propriétés immobilières en vous
interrogeant sur la qualification de
résidence principale ou de résidences
secondaires des à l'ancien principe
d'égalité
s'ils sont résidents à l'étranger il est
bien évident que leur résidence
principale n'est pas en france il ya
tout lieu de considérer aussi bien au
titre de l'impôt sur le revenu sur
parlons au titre des contributions
locales qu'au titre de liesse f
c'est bien comme étant une résidence
secondaire en tout cas n'étant pas une
résidence principale continue à
bénéficier d'autres opportunités à
savoir une exonération importante des
plus values en cas de revente de leur
bien
qui n'existe pas pour les français
150000 euros
mais pour finir monsieur le député il y
a une possibilité qui est offert dans
certaines communes et non pas dans
toutes les communes uniquement en zone
tendue de majorer pour des questions de
danse enfin d'occupation notamment dans
les centres urbains et de besoins de
logement une faculté qui est donnée au
maire
il avait évoqué la situation de paris ce
n'est pas une décision du gouvernement
merci monsieur caire la séance des
questions au gouvernement et terminer la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]